let's jump to this story from NBC News
uh okay Ron DeSantis fire staffer Who
retweeted video with Nazi imagery oh God
so um they say Nate Hockman a
Communications staffer over the weekend
promoted and then deleted a video that
superimposed a son in red over the
candidate's face I believe that's called
the black Sun yeah yeah yeah uh so this
video is super cringe ice it's got Kate
Bush playing in the background it's one
of those meme videos
so it's this video it's like Trump she's
got an irritating Boys Hey look who's
talking I know that was a joke then how
come no one laughs has nothing against
me hey someone put a laugh track for
Roseanne so she feels more at home
I never use a laptop a live studio
audience
scared of you anymore
I saw she's really sweet
that's right I ruined your secret
but that's disturbing
well so when I first heard this someone
like a a pro-trump kind of person was
like a descended stamp a campaign
staffer just retweeted this I saw Phil
you retweeted it you were like this
looks like intentional Sabbath yeah it
looked like it looked like something
that someone would do if they were
looking to harm the Rhonda Santos
campaign no that's why I don't believe
it I'm like certainly this is a trump
supporter trying to make it look like
DeSantis did something wrong but firing
the guy was the right move yes
or I think that the Santa's role in this
movie is he's playing the heel for Trump
that's what I think do you think I think
it's all a movie and it's all to you
know get people to actually have some
awareness of what's right in front of
their damn face and uh wake up to it and
yeah I think he's playing the heel
because the you know people that don't
want to vote Democrat no more they're
going either independent or they're
actually thinking I'll go a little bit
further and maybe I'll vote DeSantis but
then they're like whoa he's even more
far right than Trump so then they're
going to look at Trump should I play the
video some people can see what we're
talking about yeah I want to point out
too people said that uh whoever made it
had had something against me because the
guy's wearing a beanie with the gray
brim
I know it's a widget
me
I'm not going to play the audio because
it's just Kate Bush and I don't want to
get it coming up that hill
I think it is you're Republicans your
favorite President it's basically he's
like sad and smoking and he's wearing a
beanie and he's got and Trump's waving
an LGBT flag I'll just jump through it I
need to watch the whole thing then it
like shows to santis oh you know what I
gotta show the super cringe part when he
appears in the door like what what is
this
and then he's like wearing a oh now the
wojak is happy and he's like oh look
it's Rhonda Santa's spaceships and women
in bikinis this is good this is so many
levels of irony it's hard to figure out
if it's Earnest or not that's why I'm
like I don't believe they actually made
this because it's so cringe but it's the
end where the Nazis are Marching towards
the Sun and rad with the Santas in the
Middle where I was like okay there's no
way this is from his campaign if you
know what is if you know what the the
imagery is it's a very jarring to be
like oh oh that's where you're going I
gotta bounce myself I started laughing
yeah I did too he's hilarious I was like
what is this the whole thing is is
ridiculous here we go look bad Stories
the way you described it I thought like
oh it's in the background the guy didn't
notice it
no it's like jarring it's spinning
around God the gay out G the games do
not like DeSantis OverWatch
holy crap I hate him and so they're
doing this yeah but this was retweeted
by his campaign staff so when I'm
actually on the staff not just the
supporter no it was just look look this
is the story holy crap you're a staffer
who treated video with Nazi imagery
I'm sorry even if that Nazi imagery
wasn't there you do not retweet this
video because it makes the scientist
look like a tool oh this is this is the
Santa's campaign I I don't I don't
understand how someone had this tweet
and you probably know who I referred to
I forgot the guy's name and he goes like
uh 2020 the Santa's address greatest
government America 2021 2022 2023 like
Santa's is terrible like it flipped on a
dime well because he got he got remember
what DeSantis took measurements against
I mean he took measures against the
lgbtq plus community in Florida and
Disney and they didn't like that and
then remember just like two weeks ago
Trump had the big
pro-lgbtq party at Mar-A-Lago DeSantis
is attacking from the front I'm
surprised what I meant is I'm surprised
that how many how the Republicans
flipped overnight to hating DeSantis it
was so weird and I'm not I'm not
surprised for two reasons the first uh
attack against the dentist was
disloyalty that Trump which makes sense
decides he's gonna go to a bunch of big
neocon donors established Republican
donors to run against Trump it's like
you know kick him and kicking Trump in
the butt yeah uh but then he did it
because
he wanted to go even more right getting
rid of gay uh stuff which some you know
what a lot of parents think was the
right thing to do but then you know he
brings in Sorrows as a backer so it's
like I don't wow that's not he didn't
bring a source as a Becca he takes
sorosemite I don't think no that's the
complete that's that's complete I read
that in two or three sources you just
said 20 minutes ago you don't believe
all that stuff I read it in two or three
yeah it's not true it's complete like
okay so that might not be true and they
and they lied claiming that Soros
endorsed to sandus which is not true
either they've been they've been trying
to look they I don't trust anything that
uh you know I I want to say this
correctly but anything that has to do
with Children's School books yes and
being pro
um child pornography in the schools I
I'm not for that okay and I'm not for
anything that George Soros is for yes
amen and we're both saying this is
Jewish people by the way I'll tell you
what this may be
here's what I thought when when the
DeSantis supporters started zealously
insulting me not did they really oh it's
it's it's Relentless but it's not like
I'm you know I'm not I I don't I get
attacked by everybody on Twitter right
but they act very much like antifa style
left us on Twitter tweet in the very
same way and so at first I thought these
people are trying to sink DeSantis by by
false wagging him pretend to be a Santa
supporter like you see a lot of these
accounts that pretend to be Democrats
and say stupid things people fall for it
and then it was they said it's his own
campaign staff that started insulting me
did they really like you uh
the communications people right okay I
know them okay uh yeah they're they're
miserable at their jobs and so without
naming I'll I don't wanna I don't want
to get people dragged and then get them
yeah or whatever but there's a handful
of high-profile conservative pundits who
were pro-desantis all last year and now
will are outspoken against them because
these these uh staffers supporters and
surrogates on Twitter are the most vile
people not all of them not every single
one of course there are a lot of good
people I have friends who are big very
fine people very fine people well some
and some I think are very fine people
but
even when I've defended DeSantis I get
attacked for it
and then I get these same people who
have insulted me demanding that I cover
their stories in defense of descendants
tweeting at me and I'm just like you
people are despicable
so I'm just like I'm not having it you
know you know that video that uh LGBT
video that was uh retweeted by uh the
status war room that was made by the
DeSantis campaign they passed it off to
a third party to make it seem like they
didn't make it but they did I I'm I'm
not sure I think it's call and tell Pro
the whole thing something sentences
campaign yeah wow I think he's playing
the happy the heel something is not
adding up because the biggest criticism
of trump from even for Trump supporters
is he didn't deliver the goods and in
his defense you know he had he lost the
house you know he had he only had like
50 Senators to begin with and whatever
and the argument is well DeSantis did in
Florida the fact that he's like
overnight become like a joke and like
Jeb Bush like I've never seen any
politicians fate fortunes flip so
quickly in my lifetime
but Howard got it had a raw deal right I
know because Disney but he could point
to something specific and I can point to
something specific with Rhonda santis
what I'm leading the Great American
comeback that was his campaign
announcement that moment was like a bang
and all of a sudden people were like wow
I think you're right though Roseanne or
at least you're saying something
interesting in that he went hard against
Disney which is like one of the most
powerful corporations and then Disney
never really said anything about it
publicly yeah oh yes they do what's her
name Sonny hoyson on the
she says she drives down the street and
Florida screaming
gay out the window oh yeah they came
hard well maybe she's a homophone
Disney came hard for him yes and he
capitulated he didn't stand up against
Disney at the very end he totally
capitulated at some point they said
Disney made a statement like we don't we
don't kind of want to bury the hatchet
we don't want to push this any harder
the Hatchet by again they bear the
hatchet in him interesting in his
campaign yeah we're in the age of
psychological operations right now so to
think this just to pretend like it's
another year another election year it's
like no no dude we have deep fix Ai and
like massive manipulation in the back
and some people could be twisting this
guy's campaign in in Brazil I think it
was Brazil there was some leaked audio
uh and they claimed this position I'm
not sure if it was results claim his
politician said these offensive things
and it turns out that one of them was AI
generated one of them was not right and
this is exactly what I've been warning
about this is exactly why I said when
the Santos's campaign created deep fake
images of trump and fauci to smear Trump
and then labeled it real life Trump I'm
like they just crossed a very very dark
line and descendants
they still have to tweet up as far as I
know they they never said anything about
it they never fired anybody they did
nothing he was fine with it
I think to Santas in terms of leadership
in Florida did a fantastic job it's
great I think I think that's the thing
right because like ever it seems like if
you took off his name and you ask all
these people who hate DeSantis would you
support a governor with this record of
President they trip over themselves
there's a disconnect here for me until
you see his leadership sure sure until
you see the the mistakes made by the
campaign the the uh his failures to
address them and you've got all the you
get all these people who support him
saying that policy matters more than
Charisma et cetera et cetera and I'm
like dude let me just say I think he is
the best politician in the country in
terms of what a polishing can be in
Florida did a great job ask yourself
after all these great things why is
polls are sinking well people in Florida
feel like you just walked out on him to
go campaigning they said he hadn't half
of the stuff he was in the middle of and
he capitulates at the end so you know a
lot of people in Florida are mad because
he kind of just goes hey I did a great
job here for two years see ya but you
know that's just the nature of politics
in the United States so you get a chance
to race you have to get a billion
dollars to lose an election
I'm going to make two points about that
here's the other thing that's really
crazy if you have any criticism of Joe
Biden and social media right away You're
a trump supporter right yeah if you have
any criticism of trump oh you're you're
DeSantis supporter if you have any
criticism DeSantis your Maga it's
bizarre how binary it's got and I'm just
gonna make two points one is the
argument for DeSantis running now was
Obama in 08 where Obama was supposed to
wait his turn you're supposed to be
Hillary's nomination Obama said screw
that he got that he became the White
House so there's a path there for
DeSantis historically the other is until
Trump the nominee for the Republican
party was always for 40 years the guy
who lost the last time uh Reagan lost in
76 against Gerald Ford he was the
nominee in 80. uh George W bush uh ran
against Reagan in 80 became the nominee
in 88. Bob Dole ran in 92. so the
pattern Mitt Romney lost against McCain
then he became nominee 2012. Trump broke
that pattern so there's also room for
running and losing this is the
Republican party it works and then being
the nominee the next time thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time